gillane maxwell is a convicted sex
offender after a jury unanimously
decided she was guilty of trafficking
young girls for pedophile jeffrey
epstein to abuse
four women testified in court but many
more like sarah ransom were also victims
i've spent five years
fighting for this moment
where i finally got to sit behind her
and i got that two three second
eye contact with her
and she knew
but after all that evidence her family
still believe she's innocent
i accept
that these accusers were victims of
jeffrey epstein what i do not accept is
that they were victims of guillen
maxwell
so mr maxwell you believe these four
women
but only part of the way because all
four of them said that your sister was
part of the abuse
carolyn said she was 14 when your sister
came in and felt her boobs and her hips
and her buttocks and said she had a
great body for mr epstein and his
friends annie farmer says your sister
told her to get undressed and to get on
the massage table your sister she said
then rubbed
annie farmer's chest and upper breast
all four victims say your sister was at
the heart of the abuse and you think
they're lying well
uh if if i'm right i don't believe that
they were saying the same thing to the
authorities two or three years ago
guillen's name didn't say that they're
confused or what's the
it doesn't follow that they are lying
the reality is
all of this occurred 25 years ago or 20
25 years ago
and uh it is in we know that memory does
funny things people will think mr
maxwell that you are victim blaming and
you are gaslighting these women
i'm certainly not victim blaming that
why would i do that
ian maxwell believes his sister's trial
was unfair an appeal will be successful
and that gilley maxwell will not flip
and cooperate with prosecutors but he
refuses to apologize to her victims
well it's not for me
to apologize to those ladies i
feel
empathy
for the experiences that they have had
but
the fact is that they've now received a
verdict which i hope will give them
both
some solace and some relief from
that
pain
lawyer lisa bloom represents eight
epstein victims
i think the brother of gillian maxwell
ian is living in denial
um
perhaps that's the best that he can do
at this point i'm sure this is a very
painful time for him but he needs to
stop insulting the victims with these
kinds of comments
sex trafficker guillain maxwell is now
back here at a federal detention center
in brooklyn
prison may now be her home forever joe
pike sky news